welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
vos and the Loki series on Disney plus
gave us its first official look in a
Super Bowl spot for Marvel's upcoming
streaming shows and I just know a lot of
you were like I see you're Brady Bunch
Scarlet Witch and you're lumberjack
Falcon but ooh give me more that Loki
and I already dug super deep into one
division and Falcon on Winter Soldier
and other videos check those out but
here we're talking Loki this may seem
like a me or a couple seconds of Tom
Hiddleston in a chair saying some evil
[ __ ] but this may actually be this
Disney Plus trailers most perplexing
clue that gives us a much clearer
picture into what this show could be I'm
gonna break it all down plus the
possible clues in the title design
spoiler warning in case I predicted
anything to accurately and ruin your
life let's take a look at this clip burn
this place to the ground that's it
that's all we kid but it's also all we
need the last time we saw Loki was an
Avengers end game when a past version of
him escaped during the time heist
portaling away with the tesseract space
stone creating a new branch timeline
from 2012 onward
so the Loki we got to know through the
events of Thor the dark world and thor
ragnarok which softened the character
into a bit more of a good guy he remains
dead after Thanos cracked his neck in
the beginning of infinity war so this
Loki remains the Unruh dem 'td still
evil jackass that he was in the first
Avengers film and so he says things like
I have done this place to the ground so
let's take a look at Loki here is cuffed
by the wrists detained wearing some kind
of prisoner jumpsuit with this orange
logo of the letters T V a which stands
for time variance Authority the time
variance Authority is the enforcement
agency in the Marvel Comics that
regulates timeline Medlin they're kind
of like the time cops of the Rick and
Morty universe though I doubt the MCU
time cops will look like testicles
actually Rick and Morty writer Mike
Waldron is the showrunner on Loki so the
Douglas Adams's Eskom surveys of sci-fi
bureaucracy that Rick and Morty loves to
explore
will likely play a very big role in this
Loki series as well so with the TVA when
a Marvel character tries to use time
travel to influence events of the past
or future
the TVA drops in they first showed up in
the 80s with Thor comics and the
Fantastic Four Kang the Conqueror Power
Man and Iron Fist the Avengers and later
on they actually helps she-hulk with a
legal case involving time too
really the TVA is one of those kind of
useless bureaucracies it's never really
able to contain any of the timeline
Medlin they've set out to prevent like
thing about it a number of characters
have used the time gem with impunity the
x-men have tied the Marvel timeline into
a Gordian knot the TVA is also plagued
by corruption and inefficiency as many
bureaucracies are it's overseen by a
mysterious mr. alternate II with its
regulations carried out by clone agents
and judges like justice love just as
good will just as peace really it's
exactly the kind of agency that Luke II
would love but to burn to the ground
whether or not he's interested in
screwing around with the timeline and
every time an alteration of the timeline
creates a divergent reality as Loki did
a new chrono monitor spawns inside the
TVA to investigate that violation I
think that is where our boy Loki has
gotten into trouble we may be asking
okay has the space stone a time stone
like he can teleport spatially anywhere
he wants within the cosmos but he can't
use that to move forward or backward in
time so why is he in hot water with
Marvel's time cops well I got a theory
but before I get to it let's just take a
moment to imagine how traumatic it must
have been for Loki - get incarcerated
like this which is like the a millionth
time it's happened this guy's always
getting locked up now granted the
Avengers and guardians have proven that
every prison in the MCU is meant to be
broken out of still it's just no fun for
this to happen to you you know you get
stripped down they spray you down with
stuff and make a squat and cough and
fellas it's a pretty humiliating
experience especially if you haven't
been tidying up down there which is
where manscaped comes in thanks to
manscape for sponsoring this episode
manscaped is the only men's brand
dedicated to below the waist grooming
and hygiene if you've watched this
channel for a while you know I love
manscaped both the awesome products they
sell and how much their brand loves
wordplay subtlety that is just so
low-key yeah oops well brace yourselves
viewer because just when you thought you
had it all figured out manscaped trims
layer deeper with their brand new
lawnmower 3.0 waterproof body trimmer
it's got an upgraded motor with quiet
stroke technology dime and textured no
slip grip handle and a built-in LED
light to help you keep playing where the
Sun don't blame listen to that
like flirting and their new perfect
package 3.0 includes this lawnmower 3.0
plus the crop preserver anti shaping
ball deodorant and their crop Reviver
refreshing spray does not work goes when
you purchase the perfect package 3.0 kit
online at manscape comm you get the
biggest bang for your buck as a
subscriber you get 20% savings on your
order instantly a new replacement blade
refill for your lawn mower trimmer
delivered every three months and two
free gifts these shed travel bag and the
patented high performance anti chiefing
manscape
boxer briefs your shave nuts will glide
off these like loki through a portal get
20% off plus free shipping and to free
gifts when you purchase their new
perfect package 3.0 kit with my code new
rock at manscaped com okay back to Loki
Loki's escape from the time heist is
perhaps the biggest loosened from
endgame if you think about it it's the
one Infinity stone that was not returned
to its point of origin so even though
Loki himself may not be time-traveling
as much as he's teleporting he still is
the smoking gun evidence of the Avengers
time heist he is the piece of evidence
that remains out of place so in eyes of
the TV a Loki would be the one to take
the fall for all that timeline Medlin
that the Avengers got away with now the
meddling wasn't his fault he was just a
meddling beneficiary but when the TVA
detected that the timeline got changed
through in-game Loki on his branch 2012
timeline was at a place and he is known
as the god of mischief around the
universe so yeah you would probably be
the one that they arrest and detain now
we got some news that Owen Wilson will
be joining the cast of this series I
could see him playing one of those
justices that I mentioned oh really I
could see him as a maddeningly chill
chrono monitor who spawns after the time
ice and arrests slopey to answer for
what happened so imagine when Loki
growls the words I hadn't burn this
place to the ground
chrono monitor Wilson could react wow I
hate to hold Jen definitely pal more
timeline is out of whack and I can't
close this case why all until I get some
answers so Loki's threat burning the
place of the ground is super exciting
because it seems to apply both to the
TBA headquarters that he's in and really
to the multiverse as a whole
based on early concept art and
descriptions of the show the Loki series
appears to place the god of mischief in
various
periods including the 1970s and our
unending in-game rewatch is have even
suggested Lukey could have been snooping
around the background under that 1970s
sequence and when you examined the
low-key title card the letters toggle
among various typefaces poor vanishing
and some wisps of smoke and a green
flash of light over the past months a
few different versions of this toggling
typeface titles have been released and
there have been some attempts to connect
the typefaces and fonts to the title
letter in the past MCU films like that
first thin L kind of look similar to the
typeface of the spider-man homecoming
poster and the gold and glowing eye is
kind of similar to the Iron Man poster
and then the final metallic dirty L it's
kind of similar to that L in the
incredible whole title etcetera etcetera
so far a lot of these seem a bit rui-zhi
me and I know I do a lot of that but
really I think this is meant to reflect
the bottom is just disguising trickery
into how he might vanish in thin air
through time to burn his Timecop captors
to the ground and think about it the TVA
probably has some kind of time-traveling
capabilities in order to regulate and
enforce others timeline Medlin so Loki's
breakout could give him another way to
elude capture throw time without having
to use the time stone or the Avengers
quantum tunnel Pym tech that was never
really fully explained or justified
scientifically whatever boo-ki could
steal a new form of time tech from the
TVA like a criminal loose in the police
station
stealing all their military-grade
weaponry in wreaking havoc and from the
ashes of the TVA Loki could play cat and
mouse with Crowe to monitor Owen Wilson
Wow and others hopping around through
history as its further lynton-wolfe
burns to the ground the whole Marvel
Universe now a reminder that you could
chat directly with me when these
trailers drop on new rockstars official
discord which has really been my go-to
for theories and my unfiltered reactions
to all these Marvel updates for discord
access please consider becoming a patron
of new rock stars today at patreon.com
slash new rock stars but what role do
you think Owen Wilson will play and Loki
comment down below with your thoughts
and again be sure to check out my
breakdown up falcon Winter Soldier
footage and the Easter eggs hidden in
that one division footage follow me at
ei vas following new rock stars and
social media and subscribe to new rock
stars for all of our marbled breakdowns
thank you for watching
[Music]